la petite reine à ces petits princes 26
enfants de 8 à 11 ans qui en six jours
vont avaler en vtt 120 km deux mille
mètres de dénivelé de vibrac à alésia
entre coups de pédales coup de pompe et
coup de main voici leur histoire
[Musique]
c'est le jour j sur la colline de
bibracte à quelques encablures des
fouilles de la célèbre cité gauloise ces
vététistes se prépare pour une première
étape la plus longue et intense de leur
périple ils s'attaquent aux pentes du
haut folin le point culminant de
bourgogne très content parce qu'on a
fait beaucoup d'entraînements piges
j'attendais beaucoup ce jour pour bien
commencer miroite alésien c'est surtout
les 36 premiers kilomètres et puis on
voit bien qu'il ya du relief par rapport
à chez nous donc voilà est-ce qu'on va y
arriver
c'est ça j'ai pas envie d'être la
dernière surtout j'ai envie de rester
avec mes avec les autres faut attacher
les cheveux on te l'a dit l'autre jour
un jeune fille parce que là ultimes
consignes derniers petits réglages et
début de prise de contact aussi à temps
alexis cassandre obhrai aurélie cette
édition du bibracte les ja mêle les
enfants et les parents de deux écoles de
côte-d'or mon clip est jeune et on ne se
connaissent pas encore mais vont vite
créer des liens face à l'adversité et
grâce à leur guide leur ange gardien
jean marc et christian 25 ans que ces
enseignants organisent cette classe des
lots on part à 26
on arrive à 26 samedi aussi tous les
jours ça veut dire que si on a un copain
ou une copine qui est en difficulté on
l'aide
[Musique]
les premiers chemins forestiers se
dévoilent des sentiers souvent parsemé
d'embûches
quand ce n'est pas un caillou qui roule
c'est une flaque de boue qui piège les
enfants ou encore un défaut de pilotage
[Musique]
voilà tu laisses roule et au vélo voilà
mais la nature est là aussi sublime
voilà c'est d'aller toujours
consolatrice pour certains tout comme
les encouragements des adultes échangent
vitesse agro pignon opinions de plus
peur à la pause déjeuner chaque élève
sait à quoi s'en tenir
face au morvan et ses déchets à
l'évincer confiance en moi parce
autrement jal est tombé et que je gère
ma vitesse surtout ralentir dès que je
vois un tournant dès qu'on tourne
parce qu'autrement moi je parle direct
dans le fossé elle est très attentive
quand il y avait des chemins très
technique mais à part ça ça allait ils
sont très très bien dans le comportement
pense pas qu'on crie son silencieux
on voit quand même que ce sont deux
petites écoles rurales où l'autonomie
est le maître mot d'une classe unique à
multiniveaux est la vraie - massa se
ressemblent pour l'instant c'est un
régal cette aventure recèle aussi des
surprises à des rencontres dans un des
villages traversés ce jour là bruno
accueille les enfants pour leur
expliquer son métier de sculpteur sur
bois à la tronçonneuse
quand vous l'avez fait le tour des roues
20 minutes il ya des pièces rares
sortent tout de suite c'est super facile
à faire y en a d'autres en galère on
n'arrive pas à voir les proportions
c'est comme si le bout de bois il
voulait pas qu'on soit la pièce que si
on l'a rencontré il ya deux ans en
arrivant juste sur la première la
première étape pour le ravitaillement et
c'est lui qui est sorti en voyant les
enfants et puis en cours de la
discussion nous expliquer ce qu'il
faisait donc il nous a ouvert comme
viennent de le faire donc les portes de
son atelier et tout cet impromptu c'est
passionnant quoi c'est le charme de
cette randonnée faire un pas de côté
avant de remonter en selle et revenir
dans le dur et bien et continue en fin
de journée des côtes exigeante attendent
le groupe a pu saler c'est bien là ça va
si on peut l'écouter d'avoir arrêté
avant la fin mais c'est pas grave on
aura d'autres démontent et oui tout au
long de cette première étape chacun a
donné le meilleur de lui même les plus à
l'aise ont aidé les plus en difficulté
sur le bibracte alésia quand les mollets
faiblissent c'est la solidarité qui
change de braquet